i will not have a relationship with
nicole franzelle
uh once this season is wrapped i have no
desire to
maintain uh that sort of relationship
with her
and i don't i've never trusted her and
honestly she
yeah i just i don't like her gameplay
that's it was this season the nail in
the coffin on that
yeah pretty much yeah it's safe to say
big brother star janelle pierzina is not
a fan of her housemate nicole franzelle
and now
she's throwing some mad shade at the 28
year old on twitter
her whining and her voice is
insufferable to me it's i
i absolutely hate hearing her voice
here's what went down
the 40 year old reality star was evicted
from the house
last thursday by a vote of
nine to two janelle
you are evicted from the big brother and
on her way out nicole recorded a goodbye
message where she
formally took back janelle's invitation
to her upcoming wedding to season 18
flame
victor arroyo who popped the question
during an episode of big brother in
2018. i thought we were really good
friends outside of here and quickly i
realized that that wasn't the case
i know you probably don't want to come
to my wedding so just don't worry about
it
savage right well when janelle got home
after her eviction she found nicole's
wedding invite
waiting for her and she hit up twitter
to let fans know what she
really thinks about the fellow all-stars
i do's
quote glad i don't have to go i hate
cheap-ass weddings where the go-to song
is eyed joe cheap ass weddings cotton
eyed joe
those are some fighting words
[Music]
wait do i like cotton and joe anyway
when ichi caught up with the all-star
last week she reacted to that not so
sweet send-off from nicole
what did you think of her goodbye
message to you she told you
don't come to my wedding i mean that's i
wasn't going to come anyway i actually
have a
you know a cheer competition with my
daughters that weekend so
wasn't gonna come anyway i still will
keep it classy and i'm gonna send him a
nice gift
okay something off the registry you know
i don't know
maybe yeah we'll see and then she
straight up
went off on her co-star you guys
you know you you have this relationship
with each other um
and and then things got pretty bad tell
me how you really feel about her at this
point
so you know unfortunately we played the
amazing race together and there are
situations and scenarios and gameplay
that she did
where i saw something in her that i i
didn't trust her because she backstabbed
someone
so when i saw her in the house i was
like cool like we've got like this
little whatever
past friendship but you know i
it's hard for me to i never trusted her
and she needs a lot of like you
she's very insecure so i and i knew that
going in there i have to
constantly tell her she's good she's
good she's good
um i just couldn't keep up with it
honestly in the house and
she had such she had such an obvious
alliance to me it was like
at this point i just you know
she knows i don't like her if you could
say anything to her right now what would
you say
um stop crying be suffer
quit being a [ __ ] and
sorry um that's it
that's all i have to say about that but
janelle is just happy to be home
on monday she shared this clip of her
daughter dancing in the kitchen
tweeting quote so glad i'm cooking
dinner for my real fam
instead of the big brother fam what
would you say
to the fans what's your message to them
i'm so sorry
um i didn't make it further i'm super
grateful
for another experience another all-star
season
and i absolutely love my fans so much
and if they can please be nice to nicole
anthony
you